both Bob and myself have had the most
incredible opportunities as a result of
of Watergate and and hopefully we've
we've both taken advantage of those
opportunities to in our very different
ways explore the same themes that really
we did in Watergate which is the use and
abuse of power I've written five books I
guess to with Bob doing another one now
and you know from a biography Hillary
Clinton to the Pope John Paul the second
memoir about the McCarthy era my parents
but almost all the work is focused on
that though I still every once awhile do
a little bit about rock music because I
was a rock music critic at one point but
we've had great opportunities and sure
there been times when when I think that
hey you know can't be judged on this one
thing every day because where there's
not going to be another story like that
and but it look people have been
extraordinarily wonderful by and large
you know you walk down the street I walk
down the street people come up to me all
the time they're grateful about what we
did about our continuing work my
continuing work and look his
post-watergate been a life of hardship
hell no it has been wonderful and then
every once in a while you get hit in the
face
not at first we were both horrified and
had our instinct was not to confirm the
the report because it was a week report
in some regards and we were not
convinced that mark felt had actually
given his permission that we knew at the
time that he had serious dementia and
that we thought that this had perhaps
been coaxed and had more to do with his
family and his and a lawyer who
purported to represent him than it did
with his own wishes and I don't think
that if he was not in his advanced state
of dementia I doubt seriously that he
would have since he was so adamant
during all the time up until then that
he not reveal and we not reveal this
identity at the same time and meeting
with him afterwards and I think that we
were able to sense some real connection
despite the dementia I think he was
genuinely relieved in some way or happy
at the attention and that he was he must
have had some sense that he was being
regarded somewhat heroically and I think
it's important to understand what Mark
felt did and what he didn't do there's a
myth about our coverage The Washington
Post coverage that deepthroat through
all these secrets over a transom and
gave us the keys to the kingdom not
quite the case we a bob especially had
to pry information out of him most of
what deepthroat did was confirm
information we have gotten elsewhere
from other sources and it was invaluable
that confirmation because it gave us a
certainty that we were right even as
every day the leader of the free world
got up and attacked us of 28 and 29
old kids really at the time you know and
it was a kind of heavy experience to
have that going on and and yet we had
the certainty partly because of deep
throat that that we knew our information
was good and unshakable but in terms of
original information it came from other
sources and so this was not and I think
there's a little bit of revisionism that
goes on about this what what really is
extraordinary is that we were able to
keep this secret for 30-something years
you know the Russians knew pretty much
everything about us and we knew
everything about the Russians and this
was the one real secret in the world and
only three of us knew Bradley Woodward
myself and we were smart enough for the
two of us not to tell our ex-wives who
who it was and that would have been the
end of it and so you know one other
thing it is apparent in retrospect you
were asking about so-called
investigative reporting ah we were young
we were not national reporters we were
local reporters and we went about this
story very much like the kind of police
reporting you do and learn when you when
I first got in the business its
Washington star you work your way up we
interviewed secretaries and clerks
before we even knew any any higher ups
we got tables of organization of the
White House the nixon reelection
committee and we studied them and
getting them was like getting classified
information so we use this very basic
methodology and knocked on doors
hundreds of doors most of which were
slammed in our face so it's about shoe
leather in terms of this commitment of
resources more than anything else it's
about a management and reporters who are
willing to keep going and
and days without a story in the paper
net can you do that in the environment
of the web I don't know that's one of
the questions there's so much pressure
to get an imprint get it out there get
it on the wire very quickly and the
other thing is we were single at the
time we did most of our work at night
our reporting at night we visited people
in their homes away from the pressure of
the White House or the committee to
re-elect the president so you know we
went out we started interviewing people
and not going to indoors at seven and
seven in the evening and we go to eleven
o'clock at night so that became our our
methodology and being single made that
easier